Hello everyone and welcome to lecture
two of CME 296.
So today is a very exciting day because
we'll be talking about a new generation
paradigm which is going to be score
matching.
So if you remember last week we saw a
first generation paradigm which was
diffusion with DDPM.
So today we're going to see a new way of
doing this and see how this relates to
the way we were doing this with uh
diffusion with DDPM.
So before we start I'm just going to
recap what we saw last week. So if you
remember the first three lectures are
all about understanding how we can
generate new samples by trying to
generate from a distribution P data that
we do not know that is potentially
complicated.
So here we have nothing as input. So
it's unconditioned generation and our
goal
is to learn a way to generate new
images.
So what did we see last time?
So
our strategy was to take images from the
training set that we called clean
because they did not have any kind of
noise. And what we did is we defined a
process Q
that added some noise progressively
such that at the end of the day we ended
up with just pure noise or almost pure
noise.
And the goal of DDPM was to learn a
reverse process that was able to predict
the noise to remove from the noisy
image.
So that was the strategy. You take an
image, you gradually add some noise and
what you do is you try to learn how
given a noisy image and given the noise
level, how you can remove the noise from
that image.
So the way we went about doing this was
through likelihood estimation.
So we had our model P theta that we were
trying to learn and what we were doing
is trying to maximize the probability of
our model seeing the data from a
training set. But we saw that it was
untractable. So what we did is we
derived a tractable lower bound that we
could also maximize that could be a good
proxy for our objective.
And we ended up with this elbow
formulation.
And what we did is we expanded the terms
from the elbow from the lower bound. And
what we saw was that there was some nice
terms that came out of it. So there was
for instance a k divergence between
exactly what we wanted to learn and the
forward process that we defined that was
something that we could express.
And then the third step was to indeed
show that this was tractable and we
leveraged the fact that we were actually
defining our forward process with
gausian noise and with gausian
distributions. And the good thing with
gausian distributions is there's a lot
of nice properties which is uh things
that we leverage here. And at the end of
the day,
we deduced a loss function that was
actually very simple. There's a simple
L2 regression loss on the noise that we
wanted to remove.
All good so far.
So this was last time. And so this was
the loss that we had. So we had the
noised image as an input along with the
noise level. And we had our model that
we wanted to train which is here the
noise predictor epsilon theta. And what
we wanted to do is to have that match as
close as possible the actual noise that
we use.
And as I mentioned this way of doing
things was just one way. And what we're
going to see today is another way of
doing this which is called score
matching.
So I'm going to start with just taking
another perspective of the problem that
we have at stake.
So remember that we have some training
sets that contains some images. So these
are for instance the teddy bear images
that we have and our goal is to sample a
new image from that distribution.
So this set of images
they come from a complex data
distribution let's say P data that we do
not know
and our goal
is to sample from it.
Now a very common strategy that we will
again reuse here is to sample from an
easy distribution
and then to recover the image that we
want to sample towards the end.
So
here this cross represents maybe an
observation that we can sample that is
not part of P data but part of a
distribution that is easy to sample
from. some let's say gausian noise.
So given that what we're wondering is is
there a way to go from something that is
easy to sample
towards something that is hard to
sample.
Does that make sense? It's going to be a
bit more clear.
So
let's imagine
you have
P of X which is the probability density
function that takes in X the
representation of images as input and
that tells you the probability density
of it happening at X.
So this is what the figure is showing.
So here darker colors mean higher values
of P of X.
So if you were over here,
what would be a way for you to come
closer
to
regions of higher values of P of X?
So
the answer is let's take the gradient.
So just as a reminder the gradient of a
scalar function here that takes in as
input x which is multi-dimensional and
returns a scalar.
So the gradient of the function is the a
vector
of components partial derivative of that
function respect to each dimension of
the multi-dimensional space
and what the gradient here represents is
the direction where
this p of x is of higher value.
So here the idea is if we can have
access to gradient of P of X then from
this starting point
we can maybe go towards region of higher
density
right
but there is a problem.
The problem is that
estimating the grad gradient of the
probability density function is actually
a very hard thing to do and there are a
few reasons for that. So the first one
is that probability density functions by
definition they're normalized.
Meaning that if you take the integral
towards the whole space the integral of
p of x needs to be equal to one.
So you have this
constant that maybe we can note here Z
that is something that is very hard
intractable for you to compute because
you would need to sum across all
possible values of your space and you
know space is multi-dimensional and it's
a lot of computation not something that
you can actually do
so this quantity is intractable. So if p
of x is intractable
then if you take the gradient
it's also intractable.
So that's the first reason. The second
reason is
different compared to the first one
which is due to the fact that
the probability density function can
take very low values in certain regions
of the space where there are very few
data. So let's suppose here uh let's say
you have a point here then the
probability would be very small
and so this can cause some
numerical stability issues.
So because of these reasons,
maybe we can take a look at another
candidate of a way for you to go from a
certain point towards regions of high
density of the space. And that potential
candidate can be the gradient of the log
of the probability as opposed to just
the gradient of the probability.
Right? So why could that be why would
that be a good candidate?
Well, do you remember the first point I
mentioned regarding the normalizing
constant?
Well, thanks to the properties of the
logarithm function,
if you take the logarithm of the
numerator over the denominator, it's
just the logarithm of the numerator
minus the logarithm of the denominator.
And given that the normalizing cost
constant is constant with respect
to x the point in space
the gradient of log of z is actually
zero.
So what that means is in order to
compute the gradient of of log of p you
don't have to figure out how you want to
compute that intractable
quantity.
So that's reason number one.
Reason number two, I'm not sure if this
was obvious to you, but just to
emphasize on this a bit more, the
gradient of the log is actually pointing
in the same direction as the gradient of
P.
And the reason for that is just a
calculus reason. So the gradient of log
of P is equal to the gradient of P over
P.
And so what that means is
up to some uh normaliz normalization
you're the gradient of the log of P is
pointing toward the same direction of
gradient of P because P is a scalar.
Just remember P is a scalar. So it's as
if you as if you were dividing your uh
vector by the same quantity across all
dimensions.
Okay. First reason it is tractable.
Second reason is pointing in the same
direction as gradient of P. And then the
third reason is that it is just more
numerically stable.
And the reason for that is when P
when gradient of P is very very small
there there are chances that P is also
very small. And so if you take
the ratio it is not as small.
So that's the third reason.
So for all of these reasons,
a possible strategy for you to go from
one point in space towards region of
higher densities with respect to the
probability density function can be to
follow the direction given by gradient
of log of P which we call the score.
So this is the reason why this lecture
is called score matching. It is because
we're interested in this quantity which
is the score which is the gradient of
the log of P. One note that I will add
is
just see that I I said gradient of log
of P with respect to X.
So you may think it is redundant
but it is actually because we want to
distinguish it from another score which
is with respect to the parameters of a
model that sometimes people use. And so
I just want to clarify here that we take
the gradient with respect to x which is
the position in the space.
Sounds good.
Okay cool. So this is how our score
would look like in space. So here if
you're further away typically the score
the magnitude would be bigger because
you have the gradient of P over P and P
is small and it's smaller when you get
closer to the distribution.
So now a question that I have for you is
let's suppose
we sample from this space sample from a
distribution that is easy to sample
which is somewhere in space
and if I were to tell you if I were to
ask you how would you go from this point
to higher density regions of the space
using the score
how would you do
follow the score. Yeah. Um, so you could
follow the score. So the reason why I'm
asking you this question is because
there is a catch
because if you follow the score, it
means that you're going towards higher
density
regions of the space. But the problem is
you may always go where the density is
highest.
And so here when you look at this
illustration there are places where
density is not the highest but it is
still a valid sample from the
distribution.
So actually what we want is not only go
towards higher density
places of the region but also to have
some diversity like to not always go
uh at the same place.
So that's the reason why
let's assume we know the score.
We would use a sampling method that is
very commonly used and I'm going to call
out now which is called the lonvan
sampling. And what that does is it not
only allows you to go towards higher
density regions of the space but also
have a stochastic term that allows you
to go to explore a little bit the
region.
So I displayed the formula here on the
on the slides a little bit out of
nowhere. So we won't have time to derive
it, but I just want to show you that
there is a way for you to start from a
starting point and then use the score to
end up with a sample from the
probability distribution
and that method is called launch
sampling.
So if you know about MCMC methods so
mark of chain Monte Carlo so long
sampling is just one one such methods
does sound good. Yep.
>> Yep.
Yeah. So the question is are these
coefficients coming out of nowhere? Are
they here for a reason? The reason the
answer is yes. They're here for for a
reason and they can be derived using
some equations. So if you've heard
plank equation is something that
you can use to derive this. We won't
have time to derive it but there is a
reason. There is a reason for this.
Yeah.
Yes. So the question is um is there a
convergence concern because the the
score is getting lower and you always go
from one to the other? Is that the
question? So we will see that later on
um and see how that is actually not a
concern. But yeah, great question. Yeah.
So, uh, the question is, how do you
choose alpha? And we're going to also
see that later, but is this something
that you choose?
Cool.
Great questions. And with that, I for
now assume that we knew how to get the
score. But the the reality is we don't.
So we're going to spend this first part
just trying to see how we can estimate
the score.
And it is actually not an easy problem.
Uh and we're going to see why. So first
of all, the task of estimating the score
is widely known as score matching
because you're trying to match the
score. So here the way you want to do it
is similar with the you know noise L2
regression. You also want to have some
L2 regression but this time on the
score.
But the main problem is you don't know
what P data is and you also do not know
the score of the data distribution.
So looking at this loss function,
there's actually no way for you to
estimate S theta of X.
So that's the reason why there's been a
few papers across the years along the
years that have tried to estimate
this score function without having the
need to know the true score function. So
I'm just going to enumerate a few
methods that were out there. Um like for
instance this one is back in 2005 there
was a method called implicit score
matching that derived a loss that
actually did not require you to have the
knowledge of the true score function and
there was another method called slice
score matching which um used the fact of
projecting
uh the the score on on different uh
random vectors random projections. So I
put the papers at the bottom of the
slide. We're not going to go into
details just because these methods are
not really commonly used like nowadays.
But instead what we're going to do is to
focus on the common method that is being
used which is called den noising score
matching
and it relies on the following
observation.
So I told you that we do not have the
knowledge of the score of the true
distribution because a true distribution
is a complex distribution.
But I also told you that Gausian
distributions have very nice properties.
So one idea that we can have is let's
try to see if we can compute the score
of a gausian distribution.
So let's assume that we have a random
variable X that is drawn from a normal
distribution of mean mu and variance
sigma squared. So here I'm taking an
example in 1D just so that so that we're
uh so that it's easier.
So the probability distribution function
or probability density function is given
by this
this formula which is
analytically you know explicit. It is
something that is given here. Well, it
turns out that if you take the gradient
of the log of P, then you end up with
this very nice formulation of minus X -
mu over sigma^ 2.
Should we derive it or is it is it uh is
it quoteunquote obvious?
You want to derive it? No. Okay. Um
maybe one thing I will do is to just
tell you
why this formula makes sense.
So if you consider
a gausian distribution,
the probability density function will be
something like this. Yeah, you you'll
have high densities towards the mean and
then you will have lower values of the
densities as you go away.
So here what you're saying is if you
take
some x in space
what it is saying is the score
at that point x is given but by minus x
- mu over sigma^ 2.
So what that means is so min - x - mu is
mu - x.
Oops. So it's supposed to be a a
straight line. So let's suppose it's a
straight line. It's going to be
somewhere like this,
right? Sigma squar is positive. So it's
going to be pointing towards the the
mean.
And just remember that the score is a
quantity that gives us the direction of
higher densities in the space.
So just to tell you that this formula
makes sense.
So
back to our original goal.
So what we want is to find a way to
compute the score of a distribution. And
we saw that computing the score of a
Gausian distribution is easy, right?
So how about
we take one point from our training set
and we noise it.
So let's suppose we're given X from our
training set
and let's suppose we add some Gausian
noise and we scale it with sigma.
Then we have X tilda which is equal to X
+ sigma epsilon.
So X tilda follows a normal distribution
of mean X and of variance sigma squar I.
And using exactly this
these results
you get that the score of so we we're
calling that q sigma of x tild given x
so this quantity is actually something
that is tractable
right
so now the question is
how can we use that result in order to
go back to our initial objective which
is to determine the score of the data
distribution of interest.
So just remember at the first starting
point we want to estimate the score of P
data
which is like this.
Well, the key idea here is to take that
data distribution and to noise it.
So for that we're going to introduce
Q sigma of X tilda which is this
quantity and I'm going to explain what
that quantity is.
So
what I'm going to do is to just rewrite
the expression on
the blackboard
and maybe it's here.
Okay, thank you. Um so you have Q sigma
of X tilder. Whoops.
So it is a function of
of this perturbation. So it's called a
perturbation kernel. So you take one
data point from your data dist data
distribution and then you noise it. So
this is the one and what you're actually
doing is you're repeating that procedure
for all elements of your training set
which is why
you're ending up with this distribution.
So this is an expression that takes in
each point of your training set and that
noises it and you just repeat that
process for all points of your training
set.
And this
you can interpret it as
a joint probability distribution that
you can also note Q sigma of
X tilda and X
which is a valid one because if you
integrate over X tilda and X
you get one.
Okay. Guess I just want you to look at
this formula and just not be, you know,
scared about what that means. I think
it's quite easy. Another way of saying
this is in practice, what you have is
only a few data points from your
distribution. So it's as if you were
saying you take the finite set of data
points that you have from your
distribution and what you do is you
noise each of it. So it's as if you were
obtaining a mixture of gausian
like it's as if you were obtaining you
know you have your different points and
what you do is you you know you noise
you noise each point
and so we're going to call Q sigma of X
tilda the noisy distribution.
Yeah,
cool. So, as you can tell, Q sigma is a
function of sigma
and sigma tells you how much noise
you're adding to the distribution. So,
if you have, let's say, a small sigma,
your distribution is just a little bit
noised. So you know it just spreads a
little bit but then as you add more and
more noise it just spreads out and you
know takes much more space.
So how can you use
these definition in order for us to
compute the true score? So we're going
to see it now.
So
let's consider the score matching
objective
not on the original data distribution
but on the noisy distribution.
So if we take Q sigma of X tilda, we
have the squared um distance between the
score of XTilda and the the sorry the
predicted score and the true score of
XTilda.
Well, there is a paper that showed that
this is actually equivalent
to optimizing for another loss function,
which is this one, which is
STA theta of X tilda minus the score
but conditioned on each data points of
your training set.
And so why is this good news? It is
because that conditional score is
something that we already saw.
It is tractable.
But
we have a problem.
And the problem we're going to see later
before we do that, I'm just trying to
see if we have time to derive it. So the
deriv derivation is
in between being trivial and not
trivial. It's kind of in the middle. I
would say the proof is quite nice. It is
not required for you to know for the
exam. So I think in the interest of time
I'm not going to do the full proof but
I'm going to show you how you can uh
derive it just through the main steps.
So
what we're saying is
we have the original score matching
function which is the one at the top
which is the square distance between the
score of uh the noise observation minus
the true score of
of Q sigma.
What we're saying is optimizing for this
loss function is the same as optimizing
for this one.
So the expectation is over X over your
training set and then X tilda which is
given X
and so it's expectation of
again the score of the noisy observation
but this one minus
the true score of the conditional
observation condition on X.
So what you want to show is this is the
same as optimizing for this which is
tractable. So the trick here is to
recognize the fact that you have a
distance of two quantities
let's say A and B
which is
something that you can
expand as follows.
So
the distance between a and b^ 2 is a^ 2
minus 2 dotproduct of a and b plus
this uh square norm of of b.
And what you see is so these two loss
functions you want to optimize them with
respect to to the parameters of the
model which is theta. And so you first
realize that the B term in both loss
functions
they are not a function of theta.
So actually you don't care.
So this one you you ignore.
And then you look at just the first
term, the a term, and you just realize
that these terms are the same.
So this one you also don't care.
The only thing that you care is showing
that the expectation across Xtilda of
the dot product between the two
is the same as the expectation of over X
and X tilda of the dot product between
this
predict uh prediction model and this
conditional score
you want to show that these two are
equal
and this is what the proof is showing.
So
if you're interested in the details I
would highly encourage you to take a
look at the original paper which is the
denoising score matching paper in the
appendix. So it's uh maybe a five or six
line derivation. Uh and it what it does
is it just leverages the definition of Q
sigma and then just does some nice term
expansion and and term identification.
So all I want to say is that this
equivalence is not pure magic. It's just
math math. And what is great about it is
that we're able to optimize
the loss of the score matching for the
noisy distribution
using attractable loss.
So uh the question is the score of the
noisy data is is equal to the score of
the conditional. Well, not exactly, but
what your model esta of x tilda learns
ends up being the same. And the reason
for that is because here what you care
about is the direction where you're
optimizing your model. So you do
gradient descent typically and what you
care about is the gradient of that loss
with respect to theta.
And so that's why we have this whole
derivation to just show that
the loss at the bottom is equal to the
one at the top plus some constant that
is not a function of theta.
And for that reason if you optimize the
loss that is tractable from the bottom
it's the same as optimizing the loss
from the the top.
They're not equal. Yes. Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. Great question. Any other
questions on this? Yep.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Great question.
So the question is what is the intuition
behind this being the same? So I think
the intuition goes back to the way you
define Q sigma
and the way taking the expectation
works.
So
here what you're saying is if you take a
look at
scores conditioned on
points from the training sets. So if you
take a look at this and then if you
somehow see all the different scores
from all the different points
conditioned on these points then on
average it's going to be the same as as
if you were to actually take the score
from the overall noisy distribution.
That's the rough intuition.
Does that make sense? Okay. Okay, cool.
I'm looking at the time.
So, let's see. Yeah. So, again, the
proof is not something that we will
expect in the exam. So, you know, feel
free to just take a look at it if you're
just curious. Uh, but yeah, it's it's
not required.
So
this
is also called L of DSM. So den noising
score matching.
And again this loss is tractable because
you know the score of the of Q sigma of
X till the condition on X because this
is a score of a gausian.
So
just recapping where we are, what we
wanted to do is to estimate the score of
the true distribution. So what we said
was okay, it's actually not something we
can do. Let's fall back on an easier
setup. And what we said what was that
the easier setup was that in the gausian
case you are able to analytically
compute the true score.
So what we did is we took the true data
distribution and we noised it. And what
we showed was that optimizing
for the loss that is not tractable is
the same as optimizing for loss that is
tractable.
So in other words, you are able to
estimate the score of a noisy data
distribution.
But it is still not equal to P data
because what you want is P data. You
don't want the noisy data distribution.
Right? So it's only something that is
going in the direction of what we want.
But it's not exactly what we want.
So let's see what
Q sigma look like.
So what we want again is to go from a
starting point
towards the data distribution.
But here we do not have the score of the
true data distribution.
So how about if we take a noisy
distribution that we can compute where
sigma is very very small.
So when sigma is very very small Q sigma
is very close to P p data distribution
right because we noise it just a little
bit.
Well the problem is that if we take Q
sigma with sigma that is very small
then we'll just have poor estimations of
the score in low density regions.
Do you see why?
So I'm probably going to just explain
this. So the good thing is it's already
there. So
I'm just going to fall back on the
definition of the of the loss here.
So this is the loss that we're
optimizing.
So what that means is
that we want to optimize on the loss
that is around
the distance between the predicted score
and
the score of the noisy distribution.
Okay.
which is equal to this. So you're
weighing weighting your loss function
with respect to how likely
your points X tilda are to appear.
So in other words, if X tilda is not
likely to appear,
then the fact that it is off from the
true value is not something that is
going to be materially noticeable in the
loss.
So the model will not really be
incentivized
to make predictions accurate
for X XL that are not likely to appear.
Right?
Okay. So, does this part make sense? So,
what I'm saying here is we are able to
estimate the score of this noisy data
distribution, but we're not able to
estimate it accurately
in places of the space that are not
likely to appear under Q sigma.
That's what I'm saying.
And the problem with that is if you
sample from a distribution that is easy
to sample from, for instance, a gausian,
well, most of the time you're in regions
that are low density.
So if you use
the score of a noisy distribution with a
small noise then you will not have
estimations of that score that will be
accurate in those low density regions.
So you will not be to accurately go
towards the high density regions.
So in other words,
I'm going just to explain this a bit
more
on an illustration here.
So it's as if we were saying
that we have our, you know, complicated
data distribution here that we have
maybe noise a little bit. So it's it's
like this.
So this one is P data
and this one is Q sigma.
So what I'm saying here is we are able
to compute the score of this Q sigma but
we're not able to estimate it accurately
in spaces of low density. So for
instance here. So what that means is if
I sample an observation from an easy
distribution that is in a low density
region then when I'm going to use the
score
to get closer to that region
those estimates you know they they may
be super off.
So I won't be able to come towards where
I want
and that is the problem with a small
amount of noise. So what do you do?
Well, you can tell me just increase
increase the noise then because if you
increase the noise
then if you add enough noise
like let's suppose Q sigma
with sigma
big
then
that point in space will be covered with
a high enough density such that you can
have
more accurate estimations of of the
score of the noisy distribution. But the
problem is that now Q sigma is too too
different from your P data.
So in other terms what you're learning
is not exactly what you want. It's like
something that's different.
So you have this trade-off.
If you have too little noise, then it's
good. What you're trying to learn is
very close to what you actually want to
to learn, which is the score of the true
data distribution. But the problem is
you do not have good estimates in low
density regions.
But at the same time, if you have too
high of a noise,
well, the distribution now is too
different from the true data
distribution. And but you now can have
good estimations.
So it's a little bit like the bias
variance trade-off in a sense.
You just don't have both at the same
time in this case, which is making the
situation complicated.
Yep.
So the question is if we configure
launch sampling in a way uh that can
work then we can um
we can make this work. So the answer is
yes. So it's the next next part uh and
we're going to see how we can do that.
Uh but yeah that's a good intuition.
So the question is why is it is it poor
of an estimation in low density scores?
This
is true. It's correct. This one like not
this one actually the attractable one is
a true one. The only problem is that
the tractability of your loss function
is also a function of how you
configured it in terms of like the
expectation. So the expectation here is
over Q sigma meaning that if you if you
have an X tilda which is in low density
regions then it's just not going to have
a high weight in your loss
which is just not incentivizing your
model uh to actually properly learn it.
So it's in a sense it's a loss waiting
problem.
So the predicted score will be
inaccurate. Yes. Yeah.
Uh so the
yeah so so yeah so the question is um
how about the regularity conditions of
of the function? So here let's assume
that this is not a problem. here. Let's
assume it's not a pond. But you're right
that for instance for um sigma very
small you have indeed very spiky ones.
This is the correct intuition. So yeah.
Yes. Exactly. So high no smoothen it low
noise
produces some spikiness uh around those
training training data points.
Okay cool. I think this is probably the
most challenging part of the lecture. So
yeah, I hope you got the intuition as to
why that is a problem.
So what are we going to do and you had
the right intuition uh in terms of
making some tweaks to the launch
sampling. So what we're going to do is
now
we're not going to learn the score of
one distribution.
We're going to learn the score of
several distributions
of several noise levels.
So instead of predicting s the of x,
we're going to predict s the of x where
you're in space and sigma your noise
level.
And the idea here is to consider
several distributions,
one with a small amount of noise, then
bigger, then bigger, then bigger. And
the way you're going to use
those different score estimates
is at the very beginning.
So
if I show you my beautiful charts here,
at the very beginning, what you care
about is knowing roughly where to go,
where to go in space, like roughly. So
here it's fine if you have the score of
a distribution that is quite approximate
from the the true one as long as you
know roughly where you need to go. So
the idea is here you will use the score
of a distribution that has been very
noised
and let's say you're going to go
somewhere here
and then at that point you're going to
use
the score of a distribution with less
noise because maybe that distribution
with less noise covers
that region. And now you're you know
maybe a little bit better where the
actual high density regions of the true
data distribution is. And you're going
to go again
with lower amount of noise again and
again and again
until coming here.
So that is the idea. You're not going to
only rely on one kind of noisy
distribution with a small amount of
noise or one with a higher amount of
noise. you're going to actually rely on
all of them in a way that will make this
problem easy for you. So at the very
beginning, what you care about is
roughly where to go. And then the more
you get closer, you care more and more
about the little details.
And this method is something that you
will recognize with the following name.
So NCSN
noise conditional score network. So it's
this framework of learning scores of
different noise levels.
So I just want to reiterate what I drew
on the blackboard. So let's suppose you
sample an observation from a
distribution that is easy to sample from
that is far from your actual data
distribution. So what you do is you will
actually rely on the predicted score
from
a like a noised data distribution that
is very noised
and you're going to go step by step
by relying on scores from distribution
that that are less and less noised
until
coming to your last point which is
something that hopefully will be very
very close to the P data distribution
which is going to be a noise data
distribution with a very low sigma.
Okay. So, does that make sense?
Yeah.
Okay. Cool. So, this
so back to your uh to your intuition on
the lounge sampling. So, your intuition
was 100% correct.
This way of sampling things that I
explained with varying noise levels is
actually called a nealed launch dynamics
and it's this idea of starting with a
high amount of noise and decreasing the
noise uh progressively. So you will also
see that in the literature as ALD.
Yeah.
So the question is what is exactly the
trade-off here? So the idea is with a
high amount of noise if you add a high
enough amount of noise then
previous low density regions will be
covered by the noisy distribution
right like if you add enough noise like
with a very high amount of sigma then
you will cover it. The only problem is
so you can learn the score of that very
noisy distribution but the problem is
that the true score of that noisy
distribution is going to be far from the
score of the data distribution. So that
is a trade-off.
Right? So the direction that it will be
pointing will be roughly where you want
to go but not exactly.
But the idea here is at the very
beginning you you don't really care. So
for instance if from here from Stanford
I want to go to New York like I know
roughly I want to go this way and then I
go this way and then the more I get
closer the more I want to refine exactly
where New York is. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Um, there's something else I
wanted to say.
Um,
okay. Uh, so there's something else I
wanted to say which I think we'll cover
a little bit later. But first we're
going to cover how we're going to sample
new observations using this annealed
launch dynamics. So here what you would
do is sample some noise from a very
noisy
gausian
with a high amount of noise.
And what you're going to do is
for every noise level
you're going to run your longhan
sampling. And this is the formula that
we saw at the very beginning, which is
you add the point that you're at with
the predicted score, which is where you
want to go, and then some amount of
noise, which allows for a bit of
diversity.
And once you do that for all noise
levels until coming to a very small
noise level,
then you end up with the actual image.
So one thing that I want to say
regarding the score, you can think of
the score as being a compass.
When you are in the forest and you want
to see, you know, where the city is,
just follow the direction of the
compass. It's the same idea here. So
we're in the space space of images. A
lot of these uh regions of space are are
images that are actually not real
images. But what you want is to go
towards regions
of high density with respect to your
target data distribution.
So it's as if you were following a
compass to come at your destination.
Okay, cool. So last time Oh, you had a
question.
Oh yeah. So the question is the data
distribution can be any data
distribution. Yes. Yes.
Um okay. So now what I want to tell you
is how what I'm telling you here telling
telling you now here relates to what we
saw last week.
So if you remember
DDPM was all about taking a clean image
and then noising it. So if you remember
we had these coefficients
and for instance in this case the noised
image was the square root of alpha t bar
time your clean image plus square root
of 1 minus alpha t bar times the noise.
What I told you here also involves
noise,
right? So a natural question that you
may ask is how does the score
relates to
the noise prediction task that we saw
last week?
Well,
the forward process of XT given X0, you
just see that it is a normal
distribution centered on uh the square
root of alpha t bar * x0
and you actually realize
that the score of that distribution is
equal to minus the noise that you added
over some coefficient.
So in other words, these two quantities,
so the score meaning where you should go
to end up where the clean images are and
the noise that you added are actually
two quantities that are linked
and they are linked such that the score
is equal to minus
the noise that you added. And that makes
sense, right?
So, why does it make sense? So, I'm just
going to
clean that part.
Whoops.
So, why does that make sense?
So here if you have your clean image
and then if you noised
so it's as if you added some amount of
something
noise right but then if you want to go
back to high density regions
it's basically your score.
So it makes sense that the two are in
opposite directions.
So by the way does that make sense that
it is the formula? So maybe I can also
derive it. So remember that the score of
of normal distribution is equal to minus
x
minus the mean over
the variance. Right? So in this case
we have
so x what is x it's a noisy image
and the noisy image has the following
formula. So noisy image is you know the
square root of alpha t bar * x0 plus
square root of 1 - alpha t bar *
epsilon.
you subtract
the mean of the normal distribution
which is this square root of alpha t bar
* x0.
So this gives you minus
and then this is
square root of 1 minus alpha t bar
epsilon
over your variance which is 1 minus
alpha t bar
which is exactly what what you have on
the slides.
Does that make sense?
Okay, cool. So, this is just to give you
a parallel between NCSN
and DDPM.
So these two methods are just two
different ways of noising your sample at
the end of the day because one is
is taking some weighted average between
the clean sample X0 and the noise and
the other one is just adding noise with
just sigma. So that is the reason why
this so DDPM
you will see it be correct charact
characterized as being variance
preserving because if you take the
variance of XT is going to be roughly
equal to one
and this is assuming that you know your
X0 are like normalized they have a mean
of zero and variance of one. So if you
take the variance of XT it's roughly
alpha t bar plus so square root of alpha
t bar squared plus square<unk> of 1 -
alpha t bar squ which is equal to 1
roughly
and this formulation
the
ncsn1 is going to be
mentioned as being
variance exploding. Oh, I'm going I have
to go way back in the slides. This one
is going to be variance exploding
because you're going to add more and
more noise and the noise is going to
just increase a lot. So, it's not
bounded by like one.
Okay, cool.
So, so far what we've seen is noising
images
using a discrete set of noise
increments.
But one could argue that these
discretization
is arbitrary.
It is something that you need to decide
before starting your training process.
So one idea is to actually consider
continuous evolution
instead of discrete one.
So the reason why you would be
interested in doing that is because we
also have you know a field of math which
is in um differential equations that
have a bunch of very convenient toolkits
to solve these kinds of equations. So
one idea is to actually start from what
we saw in DDPM and NCSN
and try to see how how they would be
like in the continuous world.
So in order to do that we first need to
have an equivalent of noise increments
because up until now the way we added
noise to clean images was via sampling
from a gausian distribution. So it's
like normal distribution of mean zero
and coarience matrix the identity and
then just adding noise like this. But
what you want is to have a continuous
equivalent of
having these noise increments.
And this is where the winner process
comes in. So who has heard of the winner
process before?
Yeah, no one maybe one. Okay. So the
vener process is a type of stochastic
process. So stochastic process is a
family of random variables that are
indexed by some index t let's say the
time
and a vener process is a stochastic
process that follows
the following properties.
So we have W0 by definition that is
equal to zero.
And the difference between
WT and WS
which is an increment follows a normal
distribution of mean zero and variance T
minus S * I.
And these increments so these
differences are actually independent
from one another.
So you can think of the equ equivalent
of a random walk. So you know you walk
one here and then one there
but in the continuous world.
So one thing I want to say is that what
is independent is the increments and not
the value of WT itself.
because you can imagine that WT will
depend on WT minus one and so on. So
what we're saying is that the increments
are independent from one another.
So with that in mind, what we can do is
to derive a continuous formulation
of DDPM and NCSN.
So in the in the interest of time, what
I'm going to do is to only derive the
DDPM
the DDPM case.
So what we're saying is
we're starting from the update formula
that adds noise to a less noisy image.
And what we want is to obtain a
continuous way of expressing that. So
I'm just going to rewrite what is on the
slides. So xt is equal to square root of
1 - beta of xt -1 plus roo<unk> of beta
* epsilon. So if you remember beta is
your noise schedule. It's the amount of
noise that you add at each time step.
And so what you want
is to have an expression of
a differential evolution in x
as a function of everything else.
So what I'm going to do is subtract that
quantity with xt minus one
and then have t and t minus one be very
very small so that I can consider this
to be continuous.
So what I'm going to do here is just
some math.
So I'm taking xt and I'm subtracting
xt minus one. So it's going to be
square<unk> of 1 - beta -1
xtus one
plus square root of beta t
epsilon.
So beta t is the quantity of noise that
you add between two discrete steps.
What I'm going to do is to define
a quantity that I'm going to write beta
parenthesis t
which is the rate of noise at time t
times dt an increment of time.
So what this is saying is when we're
going to
have tend to zero, so this is going to
tend to zero, but we're going to have
some rates of noise that's going to be
non zero. That's going to be your
schedule.
So if I post that, so
this becomes
x t - xt -1
is equal to
So
1 minus
beta tdt
- one
xt - one plus
square root I'm going to also replace it
here of beta tdt
epsilon
So far, I've just plugged in the new
beta t expression.
So,
what we're going to obtain now
is actually something that's going to be
quite nice.
So
if we tend t to zero, so if we consider
a continuous evolution,
xt - xtus one is also going to be a
differential equation, a differential
evolution. So here I'm going to rewrite
xt - xtus one as just d of x
So when dt tends to zero
you have tailor expansion formulas that
tells you that square root of 1 minus
something that tends to zero which is
equal to 1
minus half of that something.
So this is just tailor expansion. So
here I'm going to say it's
roughly equal to 1 minus half of beta t
dt
xtus one is roughly going to be you know
x.
So this is one minus this minus one
because you have the one here times x
plus
so you have square root
of beta t
but then the winner process that we
defined is such that
a small increment in the winner process
is actually something that you can
rewrite as being square root of dt *
epsilon because it follows a normal
distribution of variance dt
* i.
So here I'm going to recognize
the square root of dt * e sorry square
root of dt* epsilon as being dw
which is equal. So it's as if it was
equal to d of x is equal. So this is
going to cancel out 1/2
of beta x dt
plus square roo<unk> of b
dw.
Now you may be wondering why am I
writing all these equations? Why are we
doing this? Well, you're going to see
that when we rewrite this for instance
for DDPM and then for NCSN,
what we realize is that we have an
expression of dx equal to something* dt
plus something time dw.
So these two terms have very specific
names. So one is called the drift. So
this quantity is called the drift. So
it's deterministic.
And this one is called the diffusion
which is what is stoastic.
And
you actually have a nice intuition about
it when it comes to how x varies in
space.
So if you suppose x to start from here
and you only have a drift term, what
you're going to have is just
deterministic
evolution
using f of x x and t. So you're going to
go from x to x plus dx using f of xt *
dt. And then you're going to repeat this
process again and again in a
deterministic fashion.
So this first term is deterministic.
Now let's look at this what the second
term does.
So here you start from a point x
and you add
some quantity that is a function of
noise gausian noise.
So here it's going to be something that
is noisy. So the stoastic part
which means that if you take the whole
expression
you're going to end up with something.
So one
step from x to x plus dx is going to be
including a deterministic step and a
stoastic step
and this is something that will follow
the slides here.
So all I want to say is that
DDPM and NCSN can actually be
transcribed from their discrete
formulations to to a continuous one. So
when you see these formulas just know
that it is just us transcribing them to
be continuous. And the reason why we
want to do that is because this is going
to be uh an SD so stochastic
differential equation
for which the field already has a lot of
techniques to solve them.
And I'm just going to tell you now about
why
why the DDPM formula makes sense just
from an intuitive perspective. So what
we're saying is
in a 2D space so this is the origins
this is zero
and then we have a vector x.
So what we're saying is that an
increment in x
is going to be
negative with respect to where x is. So
it's going to be somewhere like this.
And then we're going to have a little
bit of noise added to it. So maybe maybe
like this.
So in other words, the noising process,
the forward process
is bringing X
closer to zero
and adding some noise so that this
converges to a variance of one,
which is what DDPM is about, right?
Because ZDPM you take a clean image and
then you noise it with convenient
coefficients
such that after teps
it becomes a normal distribution of mean
zero and variance one.
And this is exactly what you're also
seeing by interpreting the terms of this
equation.
Does that make sense? So I just want to
tell you this to just tell you that
these formulas are not just formulas.
They they have a meaning if you think
about each term. And here
this expression of the continuous
evolution of the forward process for
DDPM
actually makes intuitive sense when
you're just writing things down.
So uh question is why is it useful?
We're going to see it exactly now. So
I'm going to tell you now why is it why
is useful. So the reason why it's useful
is one you're not going to have to
necessarily define uh discretization
steps between each noised images. So
you're not going to say okay I need
let's say t steps to do the whole
noising process. So that's the number
one. And number two is there's a number
of results in the field of stochastic
differential equations which is
essentially what this is. There's a
number of results that will allow you to
solve the reverse process
because what you want is to be able to
den noiseise images.
So here what we're doing is we're just
noising images. But what we care about
is how to den noiseise images which is
the reverse process. And the reason why
it is convenient for us to think in the
continuous world is to be for us to be
able to leverage these results
and we're going to see this result in in
a few minutes.
Okay, cool. So here I just want to say
that this drift term f and the diffusion
g is the following for ddpm but it is uh
this form for uh ncsn and you see that
there is no drift term and it is mainly
because we're only adding noise
and
the idea behind DDPM and score matching
is actually something that was developed
in parallel.
So here what I want to say is just a
historical evolution of how things
happened and how we came up to that
unified view of describing the forward
process in order to solve the reverse
process. So on the one side the
diffusion literature had this given
branch with a two 2015 paper just
describing how you can derive
attractable loss in order to solve for
this u the diffusion problem and then
you have the DDPM paper which came out
in 2020 that successfully applied that
for images.
That was on the one side and on the
other side in the score matching world
you had this principle of using the
score to go from a starting point to the
distribution and the fact that it
alleviated this intractable
normalizing constant. And then there was
a paper that described how to do that in
the case of a noise distribution.
And then the NCSN method is actually
something that came out with a later
paper
and there is one paper that unified both
of these paradigm which is a paper
called scorebased generative modeling
through stoastic differential equation
which is a paper I highly recommend
reading. It's actually written by folks
from Stanford, so Young and and and
co-authors.
And it is from that moment that the
community has seen these two paradigms
as being unified.
And this is
the way we have seen this play out.
So now why do we why did we do this in
the first place? So our goal is to
recover clean images. So we know how to
noise them through this forward process
that we now are able to express in
continuous term. What we care about is
to den noiseise
into clean images.
And so
here what we're doing is again
predicting the score.
So this score formulation is just a
regression on the conditional score
which we saw was tractable
which is as we saw minus epsilon over
some coefficient.
And the way you would train such a model
is
following this loss function which is an
expectation over clean images that you
noise. And so what you do is you sample
a clean image and then some noise and
time step. And then what you do is you
obtain your noised image. And so here
noised image is just a combination of
the clean image and the noise with some
alpha and sigma t which can be chosen
either in the dpm way or another way.
And what you do is you predict the score
that you know is tractable
using your noised image and your time
step.
But now you may be asking, well,
why do you want to predict the score?
Because we saw that for
NCSN,
we had the the score that we used in
order to sample new observations from
the data distribution. that we saw in
the case of DDPM that we actually
predicted the the noise to remove. So we
had these two different formulations. So
now the question that you may ask is why
do you want to focus on the score here?
And the answer to that
is that the forward process that is
described by the ST
can be reversed
through a reverse ST
that involves
the score.
So I'm just going to repeat exactly what
I said. So the forward process which is
described by the ST is something that
you can reverse through a reverse ST
which involves the score.
And the reason why the score is popping
up here is
due to some derivations that we're not
going to go here but this is just a
result that comes from a paper from
1982. So it's a it's a result from the
ST world that we're just leveraging
here.
So that is one of the points why we're
caring about the continuous formulation
is because we want to be a able to
leverage results around these SDS and
this is one of them.
And so now
I want to walk you through what that
reverse process equation is about.
So I told you that the forward process
was composed of a drift term
and a diffusion term. So it was dx = to
f of x and t * dt which is the drift and
then plus gt * dw which is the stoastic
term like the diffusion term.
And what we're saying is that in order
to do the reverse process,
we actually cannot just have the same
equation.
We need to add a correction in the drift
that involves the score. And here is the
intuition. The intuition is that in the
forward process
we have added some stoasticity
that made us deviate from where the
actual data point was.
So as a result of that when we want to
re reverse that process
what we actually want to counter
counteract
this uh phenomenon is to go towards the
regions of high density
scaled by that diffusion factor.
So what I'm telling you is that the
reverse process SD is obtained through
some derivation but the way you would
interpret it is that the correction to
the drift is due to
the fact that you diffused in the
forward process and this made you be
further from high density regions.
So this is what the reverse process is
like. So it's dx * the drift which is
the original drift minus
the diffusion coefficient times the
score
time dt plus
your diffusion term. And here we noted
DW bar because the winner process from
the reverse process is actually
different compared to the one from the
forward process which is why we noted
this with the with the bar
and we're just going to conclude with
how you would do inference. So to do
inference you just sample some noise
and then again what you do is you
leverage the nice results from the fact
that you are handling SDS stoastic
differential equations. So you for
instance will use a solver called oiler
marama that is able to numerically solve
the reverse process. So here you can
think of it as a numerical method
that will let you go from your original
X back to the endpoint using the reverse
process equation
and you will obtain
your final image which will hopefully be
an image that is you know satisfying and
that's going to be your final image.
Yep.
Yes. So this one Yeah.
Yeah. So here you can think of this
equation as being a discretization of
the reverse SD which is here.
So this is exactly this SD but you're
doing it step by step.
So the question is what is f(x) of t?
What is g? So these are the coefficients
that are here. So for instance in this
case f of x and t is minus half of beta
* x and g is square root of b.
This is the same. So the the question is
this is for the forward but this f and g
are are the same in the forward and the
backwards. Yeah.
And with that I'm going to give it to
shvin.
Thank you.
So I'm going to come here and sing a
very similar song as the one I sang last
week when we transition from DDPM to
DDIM.
So we're going to look at this reverse
SDE equation and look at what is not
optimal in practice and see what we can
do about it. So as Afin mentioned you
have this Browning mo motion that is one
term of that reverse SD equation and
what problem do we have with that? So as
you saw in the transition from X and X
plus DX you have all these spikes that
happen due to the stoasticity.
And this process is the reason why we
cannot take large steps when resolving
it because otherwise you would be
approximating
a a movement that is uh something that
you look at the microscopic level. So
you need a high number of steps in your
solver to start with. And also the
second point is that when you look at
your errors that you do when you solve
this reverse SD equation, you have now
two sources. You have the first source
that comes from the regular
discretization step and then you have
this stochastic error that comes in and
they accumulate.
So, just like last week, I'm going to
paint the picture of what we would like
to have and see if we can get there. So,
what would be the right counterpart of
an SD in a nicer world? It would be an
OD. So, the OD does have this term on
the left, but doesn't have any
stoasticity.
and going through each point that I
mentioned, you would be able to gauge
how fast you go depending on the
regularity on the function of the left.
So you have some methods that can take
adaptive steps. And then the second
point is that in terms of errors that
you're committing once you solve that
equation, they're only focused on the
discretization of the left part. So you
have less sources of error
and I'm going to sketch you a derivation
for which only the highle gist is what I
want you to know. Uh so there are going
to be some intermediary results that
that I'm just going to state and some
equations you know we don't need to know
necessarily how they are derived. I'm
just telling you that that they are
there.
So
let's start from the forward SD as I've
seen um had mentioned it. You have this
f of x and t term the drift term and a
diffusion term. So it turns out that for
equations that verify this equality, you
can apply the foger plank equation where
you have this PT of X that comes up that
is the probability of the flow and you
have two terms on the right that could
be interpreted in physical terms by the
term on the left that is a transport
term and the one on the right that you
see G^ squ on which is a diffusion term.
So the derivation of such an equation is
non-trivial and it's out of scope here.
I'm just going to state that we are
going through that result
and then by rearranging the terms and
um
using an identity on PT
we can uh come to another equation that
is called the continuity equation that
I'm just going to tell uh you that it's
going to be something that we see in
more details at the beginning of le next
um next lecture.
But what's interesting about that
continuity equation is that on the right
side there is a factor that is to be
interpreted as a velocity and the
velocity is dx over dt.
So once you identify that factor, you
can come up with an equation that this
term that has been identified as the
velocity needs to verify
and you come up with an equation that is
indeed an OD and we call it the PF OD.
PF stands for probability flows.
And let's look at that equation for a
bit. So just like we mentioned a short
time ago, f and g are modeling
assumptions that are the ones that we um
had as assumptions once you you derive
this diffusion concept.
And what about the score? So the score
is also something that we can know
because once you have a model that can
approximate this score, you just have to
put X as input and and and you can get
the score. So what I want to say is that
this whole term that pop that popped up
is all composed of components that we
can know.
Okay, great. And now I'm going to
reemphasize
each side of that PF OD. So it's an OD
we said because we don't have a stoastic
term and it's probability flow because
it's an OD that comes from verifying the
continuity equation that is an equation
that is focused on the probability flow.
And one interesting thing about that
equation is that once you have an
initial condition on PT,
you can
fully characterize what what P is. But
this is something that you cannot say
about X
because as you can see here if you have
V that is solution uh that is part of
this equation then if you add
if you do V + V null where V null
verifies
divergence of V null and PT equals zero
then V plus V null also can be plugged
in here.
Uh so all of that to say that the
probability flow between the reverse SD
and here are preserved but the
trajectories are not.
>> Okay. So I went through a lot so far.
Any questions?
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Yep. Yeah. Fair. So the question is
what's the interpretation here? So we
did all these equations to uh conserve
the probability flow and the
trajectories are going to be different
and they are characterized with this
modified term on the V sides. So instead
of having this um
so you have this like one half that come
that came in and that compensates for
the stochasticity part that disappears.
So you're going to still have
trajectories that verify in aggregate
the probability flow conditions but they
are going to be different and the
interpretation
is not average or anything
specific I would say it's just that in
aggregate they verify the probability
flow property at each time t and x.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So the question is
will will they end up with the same
properties that at the end you you you
have the distribution at the end and the
answer is yes because BT is preserve.
Okay. Awesome.
And um so I'm going to draw a comparison
between solving that reverse SD equation
and using PFOD.
So uh exactly as we mentioned here the
term on the left like the drift term is
compensated for that lack of stoastic
term. And um and then the the great
point that you made is that we no longer
have something that is stoastic. But
once you have an initial condition, you
are deterministically
you deterministically go know where
you're going. So that's one big
difference that you might remember from
last time you know resembles something
that you know and as a result since the
only source of diversity is now your
initial draw you have less sampling
diversity.
And interestingly, you look uh when you
look at experiments, uh you have higher
sample quality. And that could be
explained intuitively
by the fact that the fact that you
introduce noise at each time step
enables you to explore regions of the
space that you wouldn't have explored
with a deterministic path and you may
self-correct
your trajectory as opposed to uh
resolving an OD that is only conditioned
on your initial points and all the
errors that you accumulate by solving
ing the the OD numerically.
So you have a nice interpretation there.
And of course uh now that we have an OD
where we can adapt step sizes,
you can uh now resolve this faster which
is a nice property. And the fact that I
told you that I'm drawing a very similar
parallel between PFOD and the reverse
SDE as the one I drew last week between
DDIM and DDPM. We can see a lot of
shared commonalities that I've put here
for reference.
And now let's look at how we can solve
this equation in practice and if we can
do even better than regular solvers.
In order to do that, I'm going to
introduce a way to assess complexity
that is widely used in these papers
called NF. So it's the number of
function evaluations. And what we want
to do is for a sampler to get good
quality results with a minimum amount of
NFS.
So it's a measure that makes intuitive
sense in the sense that we want to
minimize the number of forward passes
that you that you perform on your model.
And
I'm going to introduce this notion of
solving an ED by the very simple method
that some of you might know already. So
Oilers's method if you consider uh this
od dx= v of x and t dt
you can based on your initial point and
the derivative at that point approximate
the next
the next point but the issue with that
is that there is quite a bit of errors
even though it's just one NF per step
you end up with the results that might
be imprecise
So people to account for that fact are
using fancier techniques. So ranguta 4
is one of them that so I represented
here on this graph the intuition of it.
So you look at the midpoints, measure
the derivative
uh have some derivative measurement on
the endpoint as well. And if you do some
waiting out of all of this, you obtain
an update step that is of low error of
low error rate. I think here it's O of
delta T to the power of five,
which is nice. So you might you might
tell me, okay, hey Shervin, we we have
solved everything. We we have a nice
sampling method. What what could we do
better?
So actually let's look again at v of x
and t. So I told you it's f of x and t
minus this uh term on the right that is
divided by two. But if you look at all
the equations that we use in the
diffusion world, you see that f and x
and t can be rewritten as f of t * x.
So what does that tell you? So that
tells you that this od
is linear in x. So it has a linear term.
And what can you say about the term on
the right? Is it linear or?
So you would have x as an input to where
like what is the term on the right like
the one in the in the rectangle?
It's the score. So the score is what we
try to estimate as part of our
reverse diffusion process. And it's
typically something that you would
approximate with a neural network. And
neural networks are they linear?
No, they're they're highly nonlinear
after the first layer and first
activation function. That's it. No
longer linear. So you have a nonlinear
term there.
And
one thing we could do is instead of
trying to discretise this whole equation
without leveraging the fact that part of
it is linear,
we can use some math properties that
says that with methods like the
variations of constants that some of you
might have heard of, you can derive an
exact solution to part of it and focus
the discretization process on the other
part
and that's what DPM solver is all about
and I'm going to spare you the details
of the derivation it's quite long I have
attached the paper at the bottom in case
you're interested it's a bit involved
you get an update formula that has this
term this exact term on the left and
then some integral on the right and the
integral on the right focuses on the
nonlinear um on the nonlinear term that
we saw
and one highlight that I'll mention here
is that we are not solving this in the
time space there has been a change of
variables and this is what the lambda
that you see in this equation stands for
and there is a onetoone mapping between
time steps and lambdas because lambdas
is lambda is strictly mono monotonic
here so yeah this is one interesting
thing to note
And the question now is how do we
discretise this equation? Because we
have this integral now and we cannot
integrate the something that is
approximated by a neural network over
continuous range. So what we do is that
this is the part that is going to be
discretized and you have variants of DPM
solver that discretize it at different
levels of granularity. So the first one
is DPM solver one that the paper shows
gives an equation that is equivalent to
DDIM actually and uh DPM solver 2 uses
Taylor's expansion at higher levels up
to any number K and the number so the NF
for each is of I + one um
is of I Right.
And so to recap what we did is that we
started from the forward SD rearranged
the terms using properties that we knew
of came up with a PFOD that verified the
same probability flow and that enabled
us to generate new samples and then we
leveraged the format of the PFOD to
further um um optimize the way we would
resolve it by focusing our NFS on the
discretization part that that really
matters here. And here you see that uh
DPM solver resolves the OD with a much
better um trade-off between budget and
quality and the difference on the paper
you can see it at low number of steps
they're quite huge in terms of nmetric
and then just like thedim you don't need
to retrain the network when you want to
sample with this solver uh because the
objective function is the same And in
practice with only tens of NFS you can
get good results.
That was it. Hope you have a great
weekend.